problème technique numéro 2 messieurs
vous avez ici un capteur de lumière
d'accord ce capteur il n'est pas
positionné d'origine sur le robot ses
élèves de 4e du collège de lajo
d'elancourt relève chaque semaine les
défis robotique lancé par leurs
professeurs
trois équipes réalisent chacune un robot
il ya déjà au parti créativité voilà
parce qu' on leur demande de concevoir
quelque chose
bon c'est sûr qu'ils commencent pas de
zéro on part sur une base déjà
existantes mais il ya des modifications
à faire et il ya des réflexions et des
problèmes techniques à résoudre
donc il ya des compétences qui vont
plutôt s'orienter vers le cours de
technologie mais il ya aussi des
compétences d'ordre mathématique puisque
de la programmation à faire pour
robotique projet lancé par le
département des yvelines les collégiens
réalise des robots autour du thème du
sport
chaque équipe est composée d'un reporter
de programmateurs et deux constructeurs
en après une pièce enfin en forme de t
qui est servi à les mettre sur les baies
sur la poste qui quand la boule arrive
elle soit agrippé et qu'elle puisse
partir avec la bosse je programme un peu
les actions qu'il doit faire avec les
robots doivent pas faire
par exemple par exemple avec ce accueil
peut donner des coups il peut avancer
reculer
on n'a pas encore testé de le faire
tourner mais on va bientôt le faire dans
deux mois lors robots devront suivre une
ligne tenir une balle ou donné un coup
dans un objet les collégiens
rencontreront leur concurrent dangereux
et de bennes pour un challenge le 13
juin prochain